one of my early girlfriends um not a i
wasn't i don't have a slew
of girlfriends just um a gaggle
flock i don't know um a bubble
oh no it's a sore point uh but uh you
know the um
that the this occasion happened when i i
i stayed over at my girlfriend's house
and uh the mother was quite strict about
sleeping arrangements you know you you
can't you're not gonna be able to sleep
there you have to sleep in the spare
room
so we know we had a nice evening i
dutifully slept in the spare room
and then about midnight her husband came
back from the pub
very very drunk and clearly this had
been a bit of a thing
you know between them and there was a
bit of a sort of a a kind of you know
words were had like
so he just staggered off and came into
the spare room where i was sleeping in
the bed
and got into bed with me
so i spent the whole night sort of kind
of in this awkward
situation and the night the next morning
i left it was like well i'm very glad
you didn't sleep with my daughter no but
i've slept with your husband
[Applause]
[Music]
you